yeah hello and welcome whoops welcome to
this video playing Leon 28 and yeah I
was a bit unfortunate the game before I
had a really good cool opponent
grandmaster Eric Hanson floor the chess
brass which sorry unfortunately right in
the middle of that game I had to do
something at the door and add to a
result that game the position was was
not good that I had but it's kind of
pointless to upload I don't know what it
what 20 moves or something basically the
opening and yeah then I had this problem
what problem is wrong it is was not
something bad happening at the doors
just we have a we claim on a weekly
basis serisone um there is a sale from
the local farmer where I buy mine yeah
vegetables eggs and so on and they
basically have a has a small droplet go
through the neighborhood and they sell
their their things and yeah it was just
arriving but they click in the middle
and I was in the middle of that game so
yeah unfortunately that game ended a bit
bit suddenly then um okay so made
Ellicott's defense again delay on 28 and
try to get some play against the e5 pawn
and well I have some play against upon
that's pretty clear but it's his
position is also quite quite solid so
it's too
this well the upside is of the whole
thing I've got fresh vegetables which I
used to make a vegetable smoothie okay
what's going on here take with this yeah
how to play probably attack the scene
before me yeah here I was thinking it
may be Quincy for an idea just to
probably not but it has some upside him
if he takes it the D pawn it doesn't
take it okay but here before I'm not
unhappy about this I guess undermining
the night oh that's what's going on if I
take it Zook see one more interesting
but I have Queen D three am I really I
said so bad I mean it's a big porn
really okay
so I didn't lose the Queen and well it's
got something to play there that's
absolutely absolutely clear yeonji form
how do I get how do I get more defenders
there nice is convinced Katja for Kaleo
we provoke this and then g4 okay Jade
[Music]
this one we are still g4 gauge 800 is he
going to is seven yeah that is a threat
to trance 96
they have to never to move I'm not
threatening
it is not threatening it yet f4 f5 okay
five is an annoying idea k6 95 and it
doesn't work what did I say I carried it
and cook on the second floor into what
is the time situation I'm one corn down
yeah I tricked me
ah it's bad that's bad that's too bad
okay black recently Jeff that was a very
good game in some some way I mean I
guess here I must be okay I must be okay
there's no way that what is better here
but it's not easy to play so this is
this Queen b6 between Kingdom Queen d8
is always a defensive resource which
five actually does work at least check
not worse is worse return a metal
precision I actually did not see that he
can take d5 just grabbing the pawn and
covering at the same time okay I can
this is not really great and e6 is a
strong move of course yeah it took me I
mean I think I was reasonably okay here
I've got the pressure against a five and
it's nothing special happening I mean
here this this is not not a collect
sacrificed roll lame okay look see one
night I woke c7 was a correct sacrifice
but Queen c7 was strong here okay you
just did taking e5 and keeps you three
under fire okay that that that's really
strong well okay so this was the way to
refute this stuff this could be eight
here books his heavenly had and he em
and always it was difficult because he s
this is the space advantage on the King
side okay guys thanks for watching